so Travis are you are you there I am
here I've been summoned so your
professional psychologist but also a fan
of Game of Thrones oh yes I am a
psychology professor a big nerd and I
love using fiction to talk about real
psychology and I think I have here your
book Game of Thrones psychology it's the
name of the book the mind is dark and
full of terrors so what's the takeaway
from all this violence in the minds of
who's who's portrayed in their time and
in their day and what effect it might
have on the audience that's complicated
there are a lot of different reasons and
real-life it can be hard to study we
know that in experiments that you're
watching violence produces short-term
effects on someone's behavior but it's
hard to study in the long run if you
have an idea that this could turn
someone into a violent psychopath it's
not exactly ethical or practical to do
that setting in fact you look in the
military of course some people would
suffer from PTSD and others don't
others can you all not always predict
who it's going to be that's interesting
because if you could predict that would
be an amazing advance in our
understanding of the psychological state
of warriors there are people who as a
form of coping with horrible situations
do shut down parts of themself we also
know that traumatic brain injury injury
to areas and the frontal cortex that can
shut off their empathy for other people
okay tell me about the psychology of
revenge this is a recurring theme in
Game of Thrones and I have to confess
revenge you know that feels good so it's
got to be something deep inside of us we
want to feel power power over our own
lives or others and when we feel
mistreated but something horrible has
happened that made us feel helpless it's
hard to maintain a sense of feeling
strong revenge is one way of feeling
we've restored a sense of balance of
justice in the world and a sense of
power for ourselves so
if if that is something fundamental
within us and you have a clever
screenwriter storyteller cinematographer
they would portray this and that would
resonate deeply within us and we want to
see more presumably and I always said I
really think Game of Thrones is so
popular because of the psychology of the
characters it's not about the Dragons
the White Walkers of the magic it's
about the human beings they hadn't had
dragons in a long time for most of them
they're concerned about dragons the idea
of dragons be is affect their whole
lives ok thank you for sharing your
psychological insights thank you
this was fun so thanks again
[Applause]
[Music]